- All right, how we doing, re:Invent?
Everyone having a good time? Yes?
Very good. Very good.
I've flown a long way to be
here, a little bit hoarse,
so apologies for that.
Who here is a Nutanix customer today?
Got the smart ones over
here. That's good to see.
Anyone running VMware today?
No, boo. Okay.
That's okay, we can help you.
We can help you there.
We're gonna talk about,
I like to think about Nutanix
because of a lot of you that
have investigated Nutanix
or you're running VMware today,
your eye is probably somewhere else,
and that's why you're here at re:Invent.
You're here to talk about AI.
You're here to talk about
modernizing your workloads
and your applications.
How am I gonna do that faster?
How do I divert costs of maintaining
and running critical infrastructure today?
How am I gonna go and take
that to the next step?
That's really what the business is about,
and that's where AWS
and our partners here,
we are all geared towards
helping that journey.
But Nutanix can play a key part of that,
and I think we're very
unknown in that space.
We can help you modernize
your infrastructure.
I like to say that we're moving you
to a modern hybrid cloud.
We can help you to build apps
once under our NKP platform.
And if you need to run them at the edge,
if you need to run them
in the data center,
or you wanna shift them up
to cloud anywhere globally,
we can come and help you do that as well.
And then enable AI.
This is an another part of
our portfolio, Nutanix AI.
How do we help you start
small with your AI models?
We can help you test them in
the cloud at a much lower cost.
You can get started quickly.
And then if the end state is
I need to run them over here,
I need to secure them, I need
to do something different,
maybe there's a compliance region,
we can help you bring those back.
So, our story is not just
around virtual machines
and how to give you a
better experience running
your core infrastructure,
it's about how we're accelerating that
so that you can focus on what's
next for your organization.
All right, our global availability.
Anyone here actually running
Nutanix on AWS today?
Good man, I like this guy. All right.
Nutanix has 11 different
instance types in AWS today
that's gonna give you flexibility.
Do I wanna run a GPU model?
Do I need to run storage dense hardware?
Do I need to run something
that's very compute
or memory-intensive?
We can help you do that.
So, the flexibility that we've been able
to provide you on-premises,
we can now bring that into the cloud.
So, very similar to how you would look at
an EC2 virtual machine or
something today, we bring that,
but just at a much larger scale.
Intel AMX, I touched on Nutanix AI.
This is how we're gonna
help you get started faster,
a lot more cost effectively
with AI inference in the cloud.
You don't need to go and
spend a lot an an NVIDIA model
that's gonna run a large,
you might wanna start small.
You might wanna start testing an LLM.
What's my security
model need to look like?
How am I gonna train a dataset
from production up in the cloud?
I don't need to bring it all.
How am I gonna secure it?
And then Sovereign,
this is probably one of the
things I'm really excited about
that we're launching this year,
which is Nutanix Sovereign.
One of the common bits of feedback I get
from public sector, finance customers,
healthcare customers, is I
want to run in the cloud,
but how do I ensure that
my data is sovereign?
How is it gonna stay here?
So, our solution runs inside
your availability zone.
It runs inside your VPC,
but we ensure that nothing can,
no metadata, nothing is
gonna go outside of that.
So, for customers that
are really concerned
about where's my data living?
What services in US East is it talking to?
We can prove to you that that's not there.
So, that's available in Fed
Gov, it's going into EU,
it's coming in Australia
and Singapore at the moment.
So, Sovereign is really
exciting for those that want
that additional layer of protection.
And then hibernation,
another key feature of our
capabilities inside the cloud
is the ability to hibernate a cluster.
So, for a DR scenario, we
can build Nutanix on AWS,
make sure everything's working,
we do all our layer two stretch.
We test all our automation
and our blueprints,
then we hibernate it and we put it in S3,
so you're no longer paying
for the compute costs in AWS,
you're just simply paying
for the S3 storage,
which is really low.
Now, in the case that you need
to spin up that environment,
you are talking under an hour
and you've got the full cluster,
the connectivity is there,
and you workloads are restored.
So, we're using this a lot around BCDR.
We have an always-on model
or we have a hibernate model.
This is a really good
way to improve your RTO
and RPO posture, and still
keeping the costs really low.
And this is where we are.
So, if you've seen some
of the competitors around
and what they do,
I don't think they've
got coverage like this.
So, we're in every AWS region,
every AWS availability zone
with multiple different instance types
to help you get what I say
is hybrid cloud done right.
What does it look like
in a bit more detail?
So, you will have seen,
if you've spoken to some of
the other SaaS providers here,
there's some different models.
Do I need to get in that one?
There's some different models
around how their services interact
with the native AWS services
that you are using today.
So, at Nutanix, we do that
a little bit differently.
So, we start with your Nutanix environment
that's running here on-premises today,
and then we'll stretch it up
into your AWS VPC that's configured.
Now, if you're not running in AWS,
we can help you go and set that up.
But automatically, we're running on top of
the Amazon EC2 Metal Instances.
Our cluster size is three.
So, whether you are starting
really small on an M instance,
or we're up at a bigger I7 instance,
we're running three nodes
to start the cluster in AWS
and inside your tenancy.
So, all the security policies,
all the models that you've
defined at the top of that VPC
are automatically gonna be
applied downstream straight away.
We don't need to worry then
about things like transit gateway
or how we're gonna connect
to the native services
that you've already got
configured, secured,
and you're already using.
It's already in the same
VPC, so we're up and running.
And then from there,
we can provide it in three
of the primary layers,
which is the compute, so
virtual machines and containers.
So whether that's with NC2 or NCI,
our cloud infrastructure
providing virtual machines,
or whether it's with
our latest product, NKP,
which is doing Nutanix
Kubernetes Platform,
we'll make that available.
And then storage.
So, the efficiency that we bring
with storage on-premises,
we're not making any changes.
So, the code base for Nutanix,
the licenses for Nutanix that
you know today on-premises
are exactly the same up here.
There's no difference
between what we're running.
So, when we look at the storage profile,
efficiencies on prem,
efficiencies up in cloud
is really important.
Now, we're running this
on top of the NVME storage
that's provided inside
the bare metal instances.
So, in terms of if you've done
an EC2 VM configuration today
and you are selecting your IOPS,
or you're selecting how
much throughput you want,
you don't need to worry
about that configuration.
I like to call it unknown knowns.
You know you're probably gonna get slugged
with an IOPS charged
somewhere or a call somewhere.
That doesn't really occur with Nutanix
because everything is
running on the NVME drives
on the bare metal itself.
That said, we can expand those with EBS
and we do have some
integration points coming
with our third party
storage providers over there
later in the year.
And then networking and security.
So, whether it's micro-segmentation,
or whether it's just layer
two stretching over here,
we can stretch that across.
So, we're not just bringing
what you have today on-premises
to the cloud.
We want to modernize as you're doing it.
So, that may be layer two and
then micro seg on day one.
And then we look at integration
with all the other native AWS networking.
But that's how we're really gonna help you
to modernize on that step journey.
All right, well, that doesn't
come across really nice.
So, we've all seen like an 80-20 rule.
I like to call it the 80-2026 rule.
80% of enterprises are using AI today.
Everyone here is probably dabbling in it
in some form or another.
Adopting Kubernetes.
Everyone's modernizing their apps,
they're going serverless,
they're using containers.
How are we doing that?
That's what's differentiating
your business.
As you look forward in five or 10 years,
you're not sitting there going,
"Oh, virtual machines
are the greatest thing
and they're gonna help
my business forward."
They're not.
It's all focused on how we're
modernizing our applications,
how we're using AI against the
datasets that we already run.
And all that's being done in the cloud.
But virtual machines are
still powering 80 to 90%
of the workloads that are
running your organization today.
They're all still running
on virtual machines.
So, while you are here focused
on how am I gonna modernize,
how am I gonna integrate with AI?
I've still got this huge run component
that I need to ensure is smooth,
I need to ensure it's cost efficient,
and I need to make sure
that it's compliant
with whatever we're doing.
And this holds all of the
data that you wanna get
and train with your LLM
that you need to do inference against.
This is where all the applications live
that you wanna modernize
and you wanna move.
Now, before I joined Nutanix,
I worked at AWS for quite a while.
And I say start right,
and I say start with a
modern hybrid cloud platform,
because what we see is that 50%,
and this is Gartner's information,
not just my made up figures.
So, 50% are not gonna achieve their cloud
and AI vision by 2029.
This is just where it's at.
And those of you that have
been involved with AWS
or cloud for a while, you'll
see that it really does happen.
Everybody gets stuck
somewhere on the journey.
And 60% of organizations that
went down a cloud first path
with Kubernetes adoption
have just stopped completely.
And why is that?
So, interoperability first,
how do I ensure that what I'm
building up here in the cloud
is gonna talk to what
I've got on-premises?
How do I know that the latency
that I'm running at an
edge site is not going
to negatively impact the
workloads that I'm building in the cloud?
Interoperability between multiple systems.
If I'm using Windows workloads
or SQL workloads that are really old,
I can't modernize them out of it.
How is that gonna talk
to the new workloads
that are coming up in the cloud?
Security, we all had shadow IT that was,
I don't know, seven, eight years ago.
That was the term security around it.
How often have we seen something like, oh,
my S3 bucket wasn't secured.
In a new environment or in
an enterprise environment,
we're seeing a very, very
brownfield, greenfield approach.
There's a team that manage the cloud,
and then there's a team that
manage your infrastructure
on-premises, so bimodal
operations severely impacts
how you run your organization.
And the security flow on from this is,
is really negative in terms of the team
that have secured on-premises
have probably been doing it
for 10 plus years.
They know the security
compliance that they need to hit,
they know the data retention
policies that they have.
But when you've gone
and built a landing zone
up in the cloud, has
that translated across?
Probably not, because this
team is all brand new.
They haven't been working
in this environment
that's been servicing your business,
that 90% of the workloads
for the last 10 years.
So, they haven't evolved, so
they're starting off fresh.
So, security plays a huge factor
and we see a lot of cloud migrations pause
because the security models
up there are just incorrect.
My favorite one, especially
when I start talking about
the value of Nutanix in
AWS, is around costs.
I wish I had just got paid on
the times that people said,
"I was told it was gonna cost me this much
to get into cloud, I've already spent that
and I'm only six months into my journey."
That is my most common piece
of feedback I get from anyone
that's going on that
infrastructure transformation.
If you think about
taking a virtual machine
and modernizing that into cloud itself,
it's not a single task.
Going into Kubernetes, it's
not a single hypervisor change,
like moving a a VMware VM to Nutanix,
that's just a simple reboot.
Taking that VM and figuring out
all the dependencies around it
and then putting that into
a cloud native construct,
that's weeks if not months.
And that's the easy apps.
If we start taking
three-tier monolithic apps
that have been running for 10 years,
we're talking 12 months plus
for just an individual workload
that's gonna go up there.
So, it's not just the infrastructure costs
that come into play, it's the
modernization costs around it.
And then my favorite one
in here is that you'll get,
you'll say in five years,
I'm gonna be cloud first.
I'm gonna have everything cloud native.
And you'll get three or four
years into that journey,
and then what's gonna happen?
You haven't migrated enough
workloads up into the cloud.
And so all of a sudden I
have to repurchase hardware,
I have to repurchase licenses on-premises.
None of this was factored
into my TCO or my ROI
as to why I said the cloud was gonna work
for my organization.
This is a key reason,
again, why these fail.
And complexity, like I touched
on a bit on the applications,
but the complexity around
workload modernization
is really there.
The simple ones are really simple
and they're the low hanging fruit.
If you're already testing,
they're probably already done.
But the partners that
are doing the longer tail
of the three-tier architecture apps,
it's taking a lot longer time.
So, we're here to help and
we help by starting off
with Nutanix Cloud Clusters.
So this is NC2. We've
got a lot of acronyms,
just ask me if you need,
so, we've got Nutanix cloud clusters,
so this is where we start.
This is hybrid cloud done right.
So, the same license, same code base,
same everything from Nutanix on-prem.
We stretch it up into AWS
and you can just move
your workloads at will.
No problems there at all.
And then from there we've
got cloud management,
a single tool that can look at
AWS native, EC2, S3 storage,
as well as all the policies
that run on-prem today.
So, you can pick up the blueprints
that you've spent a long
time designing, automating,
architecting, and now I can apply that
to a native S3 bucket, or I can
apply it to a native EC2 VM,
or I can apply it to a virtual machine
that's running on top of NC2 in AWS.
Really important that this is here,
and it integrates with all
the tools you run today.
So, whether it's Terraform,
whether it's Ansible,
doesn't really matter,
we're just gonna call that,
but we're gonna give it to you
from a single pane of
glass right at the top.
And then we've got, and that one's NCM
if you want another acronym.
And we've got NKP, so
our Kubernetes platform.
We understand that as you start
moving individual workloads
over to Kubernetes, it's okay,
and you can run the distribution
and it's pretty easy to manage.
But when you start looking
at it at an enterprise scale,
what data needs to be persistent
with the Kubernetes workloads?
What data is non persistent
How am I managing this
distribution across the edge,
across the core, across the cloud?
Maybe I need to put it in another cloud,
because I can't find the service I need.
How are you going to manage that?
So NKP is gonna help you do that.
Again, all through that
single seamless pane of glass
to enable you to get faster,
manage the distribution
and the workloads that are going in.
And then our Enterprise AI.
So, NAI, another one for us.
So, NAI is here so that
you can scale the security,
the policies, the data from the core,
which is gonna run in the data center.
You're gonna pick up
that data from the edge,
ingest it into the core,
run your models against it,
and then bring it up into the cloud.
Then you're gonna run
different metrics against that,
whether it's analytics,
whether it's training a different model
that then you can push back down.
So, we see that the AI
requirements around organizations
are changing on a day-by-day basis.
You can't go through and
buy an entire farm of NVIDIA
and put it on-premises.
It's not gonna work. It's
gonna be too expensive.
And then what if that fails,
and you've now shifted a core workload
or a core application onto that?
You need to be able to stretch it up.
You must be able to do it.
And that's where our AI
security model within AI
is gonna enable you to do that.
So, we start nice and easy
with Nutanix Cloud Clusters,
manage it all through NCM,
NKP will get your applications and AI.
So, on the right, you've got your future
and this is what is gonna
make your now a lot easier.
All right, some customer highlights here.
So, another acronym I haven't
talked about today, NDB.
So, Nutanix Database service on NC2.
For those, anyone running
RDS today or using RDS?
So, RDS, Nutanix NDB is a
similar construct to that.
So, what we try and do at the moment
is really look at the database workloads
that you've got either
on-prem or in cloud,
and how we then bring
that orchestration layer
over the top of it.
So, we take the change management
out of all the database side of things.
So now we can manage,
whether it's Microsoft, SQL
or whether it's no SQL, any
of those flavors underneath,
we can put that under NDB.
We can streamline your operations there.
And because it's running
on top of Nutanix,
we can make it a lot more efficient
in terms of things like snapshot, backup,
DR, et cetera, et cetera.
This has been a real big win for us,
so if you haven't seen NDB,
definitely come and ask us later.
Speed, hand-back migrated
workloads in 24 hours.
So, three to four hours,
that's not even close.
So, 52 minutes it takes once
you have your AWS account ID
and you go into the Nutanix portal
and you say, go build me a cluster in AWS,
50 minutes and you're up and running.
Then another hour after that,
you configure layer two.
That way your IP preservation
when you need to go up
in the cloud is there
and ready for you to go.
So, in under two hours,
you've stretched on-prem into the cloud.
You can enable mass workload
migration at that point.
You're not as worried about dependencies,
because you can start moving
VLAN by VLAN, rack by rack.
You don't need to really piecemeal
each individual workload or each server.
We can pick up a whole lot more
and move them up at
the same point in time.
If you're running Nutanix
today, that's really easy.
If you're coming from another
hypervisor on-premises
or in another cloud, maybe an
Azure VM, something like that.
It's just a single reboot, okay?
And we can stretch it from
Azure back over to AWS
and do that.
And the simplicity, our DR
solution has been something
that's really, really evolved
over the last six to 12 months,
and we've got some new
product announcements
coming with that one in January,
but two flavors for that.
So, the first one is our MST product.
That's the hibernation
that I spoke about before.
And the second one is pilot light.
So, we run that three-node cluster.
It's really light, it's really small,
and that protects your tier zero workload.
So something that I can't
have any downtime for,
we're really low.
If that's inter AWS, so
AZ to AZ, it's metro,
so there's no downtime in
terms of that hibernated,
in terms of that pilot light cluster.
And then we've got integration then
with the third party backup providers.
So, for a seamless perspective,
you could have Cohesity
backing up your workloads.
tZero is snapshot by Nutanix into AWS,
and then everything will go
and restore into that cluster.
So, the DR solution from us
is really highly evolved.
If you're running Nutanix
today, I would say
come and see us over
there, get it started.
That's a really easy one to go and turn on
with big benefits to the business.
I'll finish off with our incentives.
For those of you that know
AWS, there's a ton there.
You can procure all Nutanix
licenses, whether it's on-prem
or in the cloud through AWS marketplace.
Everything is done through
either the Nutanix console
or the AWS one.
We've made it really
easy, 30-day free trial,
et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
Please come and see the team over that
and I'll leave you with some QR codes
if you would like some more information.
But come and get hybrid cloud done right
with Nutanix on AWS.
Thank you.